over this last year the world has
changed
like never before as we pivot more into
remote learning and remote working and
an increase in e-commerce there has
never been
a better opportunity for you to go
full-time on
youtube my name is heather torres and
you're listening to the think
marketing podcast and if you're new here
we release an episode every single
tuesday
and i would encourage you to subscribe
wherever you're consuming
this content and i'm excited because
we're gonna be getting into
a three-part series over the next few
weeks here on the podcast
shawn's going to be breaking down the
seven lessons that he learned from
going from flipping burgers well
actually serving burgers
to becoming a full-timer on youtube
this is possible this is possible for
you right now and i'm excited because
over these next three episodes we're
gonna be breaking down each one of those
steps
and throughout that time you're gonna be
learning everything from
how do you actually go full time like it
sounds great but what are the practical
steps to doing that
things like the proximity principle and
what does that mean for you to growing
faster into going full time
and how do you financially do it you
know what does it actually mean to go
full time and how do you get there
faster we're gonna be breaking down the
seven steps over the next few weeks and
today
we're jumping into step number one which
is getting started
and step number two which is skilling up
now sean's gonna share with you those
first two and then i'm gonna come back
on we're gonna recap and i've got some
extra tips for you at the end step one
is start right and there's actually
another part to it but ultimately you
gotta just start now maybe that seems
basic
but i know a lot of us even some in the
think community think uh media community
that maybe we're still hesitating
because of fear maybe we think
we don't have the right gear yet or any
of those things look you gotta punch
pier and
fear in the face punch perfectionism in
the face
and press record but a better way to
start is not just start but start
with the end in mind
and so if you want to go full time it's
good to have a vision
for where you want to go and look you
don't have to be great to start but you
have to start
to be great so when it comes to think
media
i think it's important to mention that i
started video
in 2002 or three i started volunteering
at my local church
and using video cameras to make these
video announcements wednesday night at
youth group and guess what they were
terrible
like your first videos are gonna be your
worst videos but when you look at my
ultimate journey
that was a massive advantage right
because i was learning cameras i was
learning editing i was terrible at it
and i had time
years before youtube even started to
really skill up and level up
but ultimately you got to just start you
got to learn this stuff you got to lean
in
you got to push back past perfectionism
and just start but i also think that
starting with the end in mind is
important and the first think media
video that was ever posted was in 2010.
now i didn't have a ton of clarity
but i did have a little bit of a
direction and you can see that here that
even
eight nine years ago i posted on
how to get started in video production
and video editing or
video editing pc tips how to build an hd
video editing
machine what was i doing on youtube
i was teaching out of my experience that
i had up until that point
so by 2010 i now had
been volunteering and doing video
production i've been on camera i've been
learning about cameras
and i started a business called
clearvision media where i was doing
wedding videos
and i was doing video production for
other people so
my youtube channel was like an overflow
of what i was doing in my life it's kind
of meta you know if you ever
some people like are like sean you you
have a channel about video it's like
well no video was
what i started with way before even
youtube started right
and so i realized that i had some skill
in that i had
experience i had time doing that and so
that's what i started
my channel around and in 2010 i was
working at red robin waiting tables that
was my main way to pay the bills i
bootstrapped my business clear vision
media took out a loan to get some video
gear
i had a side project with my friend jeff
moores
called think international which was
actually a major piece of me learning a
lot of youtube skills
and then i started think media and if
you've ever wondered like why think
media well
i don't know where we came up with the
name think international think media was
at first just the media side
over on that channel with jeff it was
just kind of like a passion it was
actually a non-profit that we started
and
it never really made money and it was a
non-profit but it didn't even make money
for a non-profit to run the bills
um and but but we learned so much and
what it actually was was an
interview show with authors faith-based
leaders and
church leaders so it really you know you
see video influencers today i was
cutting my teeth
in 2010 really learning about interviews
and video production and dynamic content
or whatever
and so think media started as like an
overflow
of um of that and i was like think
international think media i'll talk
about the cameras and the tech and all
my experience
on that side of things so i was doing a
lot and maybe you can relate in fact
tell me in the comments
like maybe you can relate to being doing
a side hustle in fact what season are
you in
i'm imagine if you're watching this
youtube is a side hustle but tell me
you're in the side hustle season maybe
you're in the solopreneur season where
you're actually kind of making some
money off youtube
or maybe you're in the scale season
where things are just growing and things
are going
further uh for you but definitely let me
know in the chat or in the comments
below
because i get the fact of juggling
things right i get the fact
of trying to do multiple things and you
got to just be disciplined right and at
that time i knew i wanted to do this
you know we don't really have time to go
into my story but i was coming right out
of the hardest season of my life
um in 2009 my wife almost died and i
found myself in the hospital and
we went through the financial crisis and
we were losing our home so i was
all of this hustle was out of a lot of
desperation
to provide for my family to provide for
um
you know our future and to really just
figure out how to make this youtube
thing work
and so i see that youth man's in the
solopreneur season that's awesome i see
kelvin starting i see uh happy ever
nancy's in the solo husson
uh uh johnson's in the side hustle
season i love it so we're all kind of in
different seasons
but i can totally relate to you feeling
kind of like that struggle
of making juggling you know things and
so
um uh what ended up happening here's a
tip for this season
is success on youtube is found when you
use your experience
passion and skill to add real value
to the lives of others and
that's what i was doing so think about
that for you write that down and even
think about that for you
what is your life experience what are
you
passionate about and what have you
developed some skill at or some
proficiency at that you can
add real value to the lives of others
and maybe type that in the chat
but see what i had done was again my
experience was in video i was also
passionate about video i was geeking out
about cameras and lenses
and i developed some skill in video so
that was the natural overflow
on to youtube i'll be honest though i
actually
didn't have as much clarity like
hindsight's 20 20. i was i was confused
at the time so if you feel kind of
confused that's
you're in good company because we
probably are all pretty confu a little
bit confused about you know what's even
happening where we're going
and so um ultimately though uh that's
where
the magic is i believe if you want to go
full time and
a couple other things to ask if you're
starting with the end in mind is is
there a market for my topic
and are there practical ways to monetize
it so like
i was like is there a market for people
who are going to want to learn about
video find cameras all those kinds of
things
and the answer of course is yes and then
is there a way to monetize it and i had
been learning about like affiliate
marketing so the answer was yes
but then another question to ask is can
i add real value in this space
and the answer was yes i had a ton of
self-doubt
i was scared to put myself out there but
i thought man
i i just started this business i took
out a loan
for like 10 g's to buy all this gear i
didn't need 4
000 worth of it so youtube or rather
think media was kind of like
the scratching the that i was answering
it was being
the guide i wish i had like i was a
little bit further in video so i was
just
turning backwards to help people a few
steps back from me
figure out what camera to get or
whatever that's where your magic is on
youtube
you probably discount your own expertise
but all you need to do is think what do
i have experience in
what am i passionate about what if i
develop some skill at
and how can i help people a few steps
behind just come with me
and save time save money go further
faster
and so that was really this sweet spot
and i think that will help you find your
sweet spot and some advice is look focus
on making money elsewhere when you're
starting
dig your well but don't drink from it
too soon now
i'm not saying that you can't start
youtube and make money even in a few
months or even
in the first month it happens and
especially when you go through training
or you connect with think media or video
influencers
like we'll help you go faster but i
think it's an important mindset
to focus on making money elsewhere so
even though i wanted to monetize on
youtube
i just like i kind of just punted it out
of my mind and that was actually deeply
influenced
by gary vaynerchuk i read his book crush
it in 2009 and it was like look
just don't worry about cashing in too
soon so here's what i'm saying dig your
well
but don't drink from it too soon see
you really it's much more important
important to figure out your voice
build an audience build trust kind of
get a rhythm down
and how do you do that by making money
somewhere else
so i was like look i make money waiting
tables and i ca here's the thing
you can make so much more money
somewhere else than you can off youtube
ads when you're just starting for
example
like i was like dude i'm gonna make like
fi if i even turn on monetization on
think media this is back in the day too
things are a little bit different now
and eventually once i got to a certain
size
if i even turn this on i'm gonna make
like five bucks if i just
treat a table a little nicer i could
make five bucks in one night
on tips because i you know i was waiting
tables and actually at the time i was a
buster even as a busboy if i'm nicer to
the servers
they'll you know what i'm saying like
get money somewhere else like go get a
job like go
hustle and then fund like your youtube
ambitions just some advice like focus on
making money somewhere else when you're
starting
dig your well focus more on audience
value and i'm not saying don't turn on
monetization necessarily or do affiliate
marketing
just don't focus on it when you're first
starting which brings us to step two
which is skill up
skill up mastery
is the target we're talking about going
full time and i'm serious about this
look this video is not about a get rich
quick
overnight magic pill those don't exist
this stuff does take work
and i really believe that you can make a
living around your knowledge your
passion your expertise that you can
share your message with the world that
this can happen
but it's not going to happen if you
don't pursue
[Music]
mastery mastery of your subject
i really believe the reason i'm here
today is because i've been obsessed
with not just being average at my
subject
but pursuing mastery being the best
i'm not saying i am the best i'm saying
i'm striving to be the best i'm in a
competition with myself
i want to get better than i was
yesterday i want to always be improving
i want to have the most knowledge
possible about
youtube that's why we've interviewed
hundreds of people
about it that's why i read about it go
you know what i'm saying mastery
mastery of your subject and of course
mastery of the best practices so i
realized man there's a lot to learn in
this youtube thing
you know what i mean like it's like man
thumbnails and titles and shooting
videos and
like plugging where's the mic go and is
the mic on
and how do you actually be in focus and
shoot how do you get the blurry
background
and actually it's bad because i was
actually blurry but the background was
in focus the whole time because of how
shallow that depth of field was all this
different stuff
there's a lot to learn but just make a
commitment when you're starting to
mastery
mastery and here's how you could skill
up quickly
number one be obsessed number two
practice and increase outputs and then
also invest in yourself
this is how i focused on skilling up i
was obsessed this is why it's
you really want to be in a place you're
passionate about like
i i work really hard and that's
been imparted to me from my parents like
they taught me a good work ethic
and um i think just general in life i i
just believe we're on earth
for a mission not just to chill but to
actually make a difference and
and and add value to the world and
contribute to others
so i do work hard but here's why it's
easier for me to work hard is because
i'm in my zone i'm in my grace
it'd be hard for me to be to work as
hard and
i worked hard waiting tables like you
need to be able to muster up
work ethic because how you do anything
is how you do everything
and if you're mediocre and average at
your job hoping that someday you're
gonna make it on youtube i think that
transfers over i think your spirit
anywhere
transfers to everywhere so i put put out
excellence but i'm saying
i was obsessed with my topic i pic
picked i would be up
late nights reading camera blogs and
trying to figure out codecs and trying
to figure out why stuff wasn't exporting
like it was an obsession so i found my
zone if you haven't found your zone yet
that's okay
keep experimenting but you want to get
in a place where you can actually
sustain the hustle because you love what
you're doing
and you want to get obsessed and then
practice and increase
outputs you know if you want to develop
mastery in something but you only work
on it one hour a month
it's going to take you a freaking long
time to develop mastery in it
but if you could work on it one hour a
week it's going to be faster if you
could work on it five hours a week it's
going to be faster
what if you could work on it 20 hours a
week but sean
i've got you know kids and i've got a
family and i've got stuff
you may have 20 hours a week that you
could still recover
i mean if you if you let go of some
netflix if you let go of some leisure
if you got a little bit more disciplined
and didn't call working
just scrolling through youtube and
researching other people's content
if you got real focused and so if you
can increase the amount of practice
you're putting in look if you take
more shots then you get better form over
time with coaching
and you eventually make more baskets
if you're in your grace zone and so
increase the outputs i was in the season
just trying to do as much stuff as i
could
in my zone so i was freelancing i was
shooting editing videos shooting videos
because i knew that i was like oh i like
this space and i want to be in this
space so i want to just
immerse myself and put out as much
content being as prolific as possible
today
i've uploaded over 2000 videos either
for myself or for clients or for
churches i've worked for
i've put out a lot of content when you
put out that much volume you get to
mastery quicker
and then invest in yourself the how to
skill up quickly is also
invest in yourself so
uh whether that's courses books reading
all those types of things
during all of these seasons that's what
i was doing because i was wanted to get
the skills necessary to succeed and
thrive in this industry
jim rohn says formal education will make
you a living
but self-education will make you a
fortune
and so invest in yourself
education doesn't stop and by the way i
know i'm preaching to the choir if
you're here on the replay or you're here
live and think media clearly
you believe in investing in yourself
because you could be
watching netflix but you're here
studying to level up your
future in your career so i really
applaud that and i want to encourage you
and thank you for being here
but i i believe this so wholeheartedly
the average person stops learning when
they
end high school or college but you gotta
keep learning
continuous learning lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners so i've never
hesitated to invest in books and courses
and events
because it's what has helped me skill up
faster
and so some advice is also volunteer in
an organization where you will learn
critical
hard and soft skills
volunteer at an organization where you
will learn critical
hard and soft skills what do i mean i
think that
as i look back one of the critical
components to
going full time on youtube and the
skills i developed to do it
was because i started volunteering at a
church in 2003
and whether you volunteer at your church
a
church a local non-profit some kind of
an organization or
you volunteer at a business i mean work
for free
volunteer at a business or for a
youtuber or for a production
house or for a media company you want to
volunteer in an organization
where you will learn critical hard and
soft skills what are hard and soft
skills
hard skills are where you will learn
youtube
so the first youtube channel i managed
was 2007 for my church
little did i know that even though i had
no clue what i was doing and titles
i was clocking time i was developing
mastery by putting in
uploading videos and and back then there
was a 15 minute time limit so anything
longer than 15 minutes we'd cut into
multiple parts
we'd upload those tagging them trying to
figure out stuff
making a ton of mistakes but i was
learning hard skills
like lighting and cameras in immersed
in this church but then also soft skills
like
relationships leadership teamwork
how to win friends and influence people
which is a great book but you
like people skills communication skills
soft skills emotional intelligence i
think you need that for youtube i think
you need
that to succeed you need to have a vibe
where you can kind of
sense where people really are where your
audience is going so i was learning both
sides
i want to encourage you have you ever
considered volunteering you're sitting
around
wanting to grow and you may have time
this isn't for everybody but you got
some time
this could be the fastest way that you
could level up i read this in a book
called rich dad poor dad by robert
kiyosaki another classic where he said
look the fastest way to level up is go
volunteer
plus you'll get around other leaders
other people by the way the best
possible people in the world are
volunteering
aren't they i mean they are because
they're they have servants hearts
they're leaders they believe in
something different they're bigger
they believe in something bigger they're
mission driven so i
just that one thing snowballed my life
to just level me up plus the education i
was getting there from a spiritual
leadership
all of the different aspects and so
volunteer consider this is some advice
volunteer in an organization where you
will learn critical heart and soft
skills
well that was step number one and step
number two let's recap step number one
was start before
you're ready and step number two was
skill up and
you know when i think about my journey
even getting here to being able to do
this podcast for you bringing you as
much value as i can about
getting started on youtube growing on
youtube and ultimately creating a life
that you love
with the power of video i think about
when i started
i was so scared i mean let's be honest
it is not easy to step outside the norm
quit your job and decide to go full time
on youtube
and i remember that i just knew i needed
to step
outside of my comfort zone i knew that i
needed to get around the people that
were gonna level me up and
i knew i needed to learn those skills
like sean said those hard skills and
soft skills and i spent
years volunteering i spent years being
in the spaces that i knew were gonna
help me grow
some things worked and some things
different didn't but i just knew
that if i mastered one and two if i just
started if i
pat picked up the camera if i started
making little snapchats if i
just got myself into an uncomfortable
position that it was gonna help me grow
and that's what i want for you
you know right now we are seeing some
unprecedented times it
is unimaginable what's even happened but
the opportunity
is there for those who see it and i want
to encourage you to
go all in to not hold back when it comes
to
chasing your dreams it's so important to
remember
that you are the one that can create the
life that you want but you have to step
outside the comfort zone
and start messy and know that there's
probably going to be people that are
judging you on the outside but that you
can stay focused on what matters most
and that is going full time on youtube
if that's the plan
so i just want to encourage you that as
you walk through these different steps
that we're going through
that you take time to write down things
like am i challenging myself
am i doing things that are going to help
me skill up
am i in the position that i want to be
in to be
able to go full time we have more steps
to come so don't worry
we're going to be covering the rest of
the steps in the next two episodes and
i'm excited about that
but i want to let you know that as we
walk through these
seven steps that this is your challenge
to take action
if you've not started your youtube
channel and you're listening to this
right now
then your next step actually is probably
to go and start your channel
and if you need help on what that looks
like or how to do it
you can always check out our think
master class it is our free
youtube class where sean breaks down the
three secrets to success on youtube
now if you're gonna start on youtube i
want you to start the right way i don't
want you to feel
lost and unsure about what to do and so
you can register for that free class
at thinkmasterclass.com and sean's
really put
so much time and effort into making sure
that he's bringing you
value in this class that's going to move
you forward that's going to help you
dominate on youtube
that's going to help you move from
dabbling to actually dominating
and help put the pieces together to what
youtube can be like
for you so you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com if that is your
next step
to take here on the podcast now if you
haven't subscribed yet to the podcast
i'm gonna encourage you to click
subscribe wherever you're watching and
if you're on itunes you can rate and
review this podcast i love
being able to go over and read the
ratings and reviews that are posted over
there
and today we have one from seeker bear
seeker bear says
knowledge overload valuable information
great guests and entertainment all in
one thank you for
all your content on all platforms
well thank you so much for being a part
of the community you know it's our heart
here at think to help 10
000 people create a full-time income
doing what they love and making an
impact in the world with the power of
video and that can be you
you can be one of our ten thousand so
thank you for being a part of our
community here at think it means
so much to us to get to hear your
stories
all over social on youtube and on
instagram
and here on the podcast and we just want
to say thank you for being a part of the
community
next week's episode we're gonna be
diving into step three
and step four and you're gonna learn all
about the proximity principle and how
that can help you get to your goal
faster
and if you're in a season where you're
trying to figure out how do i get this
side hustle done
we're going to be breaking down how you
can do more in less time
and get to your goals faster yeah
both of these new steps are going to
help you get to your goal faster and
that's important
to brush off years from what it will
take for you to get there
so i can't wait to see you in the next
episode thank you so much for listening
i hope that this one was helpful to you
and now it's time for you to take action
take the action
either go watch the master class or get
started on your youtube channel
and i'll see you in the next episode
[Music]
you